Well, good morning, everyone. Thank you for attending our session of
Academic Entrepreneurship and Getting Discoveries into Patients,
part one, and there's two parts, and you'll hear about the second part a little bit
into our program this morning.
So my name is Mike Caligiuri, and I'm going to have our panelists
introduce themselves shortly.
I'm going to just tell you that the lights are so bright that we
really can't see you.
So if you have a question, you can come up to the microphone, and
we're hoping there's lots of questions because this is a
discussion
that we
want to have with you, very interactive discussion.
So,
just to make sure you're in the right place, if you're pursuing a business
opportunity or have an idea to do so,
looking to gather the resources, looking to take on some financial risk
or your institution take on some financial risk,
and you want to
start a new innovative venture with the aim of
making a profit, even if it's non-for-profit,
making some money,
bring your idea to reality,
when you're not necessarily in a position yet to do so, you're in the right
place. Because that's what we'd like to talk about today.
And we'd like to start with just
rather lengthy introductions from each of our panelists who have very
distinct career pathways.
And
I'll give my own introduction at the end of that, because I think that will
help direct your questions and your comments,
and
you may resonate more with one person or another.
So to my
far left, we have Dr. Vanessa Almendro,
and then we have Dr. William Heit, and then we have Dr.
Omer Butt.
And I'm Mike Caligiuri, as I mentioned.
So,
I'm going to start with Vanessa,
Dr. Almendro, to really take
10 minutes to talk about her career, and both as
an entrepreneur,
and as well as her current position and what she does in
her current position as a chief technology officer. So, Vanessa.
Thank you. Well, good morning, and thank you everyone for being here in the first
session, 8:00 a.m. with us.
As Mike mentioned, my name is Vanessa Almendro.
I am the chief commercialization officer at City of Hope.
And I'm going to tell you a little bit about how I went around
my career to end where I am today. I'm actually a scientist by training.
I have a PhD in biochemistry, and I was faculty in academia for nine
years, having my own lab at the hospital clinic in Barcelona, where
I was driving
the lab of translational oncology and working as well at the
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, where I was a visiting scientist,
in Cornelia Poliak lab, actually, many years ago.
And when I was faculty in academia and I
was running my research, I was always very
motivated to think about how could I advance the science that I
was doing to actually make products for patients.
I had, unfortunately, way too many cases of cancer in my family, and I was
always very motivated to see my science going beyond
just
publishing a paper or having to apply for grants.
I was able, through my research, to get my first
patent application. That was for an antibody against substance P.
Substance P is a very small neuropeptide involved in
cancer. We're unsure what was the mechanism of action, but we found that
it was transactivating EGFR and HER2.
It's a small neuropeptide, so there were no way that we could develop a small
molecule. We were able to develop an antibody against substance P,
and then the Office of Technology Transfer at the University of Barcelona
grant me with a very nice package, actually, to take this idea
and this IP and think about starting a company so that we could
commercialize the product and actually get it to the patients.
And that was a very important milestone in my career, where I
just realized that, and again, many years ago,
that I had no idea what comes next. What do you do once you
have your patent? What comes next?
What does it mean building a business case? How do you go and pitch to investors?
All that was extremely,
honestly, unclear to me. And I had not
enough support from the institutions where I was working on to really
guide me into what do I need to do next.
And that was a critical moment where that really triggered me to
decide to leave academia and go to the private sector, to industry, to
really understand how do you go from having a good idea and a good
patent to actually develop a product that can make it to the
patients. Something I want to mention as I was transitioning
from academia to industry is that, at that time,
I remember that there was this concept that going to industry was
taboo. You are a faculty. You are in academia.
Commercialization is not something that we do.
But in my head, that was precisely what I had to do because the only way you can
get innovation to a product that goes back to the patient is
through commercializing that product.
So for me, commercialization was part of what I had to do as
a translational scientist trying to make impact
with patients. So I left Dana-Farber, and
decided to join Vertex Pharmaceuticals, where I
was lucky enough to be given the opportunity to
run the lab for translational oncology, basically
continuing to do new target discovery for Vertex oncology
programs. And with that,
starting to be more exposed into what drug development
means.It was a jump. It was, for me, really starting
almost from zero because I had no idea how drug development
works, how were you doing your drug development programs,
screening. But it really gave me the opportunity to start
seeing more how industry works, and again, what are the critical steps
to go into lead identification, lead optimization, and so on and so
forth. And, at that time, as I was starting to find
new targets and building new
proposals for us to build in our portfolio,
I was working with a commercial team and with business development and with a
clinical team that were telling me sometimes that my
ideas had not development path. They were not commercially viable.
And I was all surprised again. That was another moment in my career that
I was like, "What do you mean I cannot develop in this
target, or this is not commercially viable?"
And this
prompted me to really rethink again my career after two years running
a translational new target discovery at Vertex
to make another
big choice and a risky one that was leaving my
role in the R&D department to actually join the commercial
department so that I could really see from the other side,
what do you mean? How do you go into actually running
clinical trials? Why the endpoints are so important for
the statements and the marketing material and many other components.
I started then being much more exposed to
the business side of things, um, and realizing of
all that gap that I had decided to go to MIT and do an executive
MBA. So it was tough. Trust me, like starting over my career
again with zero knowledge about commercialization, getting to
do an MBA in the middle of all this. But it really gave me
these two transitions within such a short period of time, gave
me the knowledge and the
perspective,
high level enough to be able to really see what are all the critical steps to
go from an idea to actually a commercial product.
After this, at Vertex, I left Vertex,
joined Repertory Immune Medicine, one of the flagship companies, to build a
portfolio strategy, then transitioned to work at Eisai
Pharmaceuticals to also run portfolio strategy and external innovation,
working now in neurology, in Alzheimer's.
And then I was recruited to Danaher Corporation, not a pharmaceutical company,
a life sciences company, to be the head of innovation across a
portfolio of 20 companies in diagnostics,
manufacturing, biotechnology, genomic medicines, and many other domains.
The reason I'm sharing this with you is because one of the aspects that as a
translational scientist was really important for me was that at the moment I
got the tools to understand how the process looks
like and the framework to think about commercializing
innovation. I was able to apply this to many other
domains. I did not get stuck into my expertise that was oncology, but
I was able to jump into immune disorders and neuro and
Alzheimer's and even the life science industry, working on instrumentation,
something that I've never done before.
But the framework, the thinking, how do you go about an idea to a
commercial product, can be applied across multiple
domains. And then the last thing I want to mention,
I think I'm still in my 10 minutes.
No, you're good.
I am.
This is important.
Is that
this was an amazing journey transitioning.
Again, I took the risk, and I knew that my career was going to be
having several lateral moves until I was going to be able to
take all this knowledge and do something impactful with it.
And I want to share that I feel that that moment
has come right now. After all these many years
transitioning through multiple roles in industry, I had the
opportunity now to go back to an academic medical center, a
hospital system at City of Hope, where we are going to
try to do precisely what I tried to do many years ago, to really
build an engine by which we can bring the best of the
academic medical research to the rigor and the process, the way
that we think in the industry, and try to really translate innovation in a
different way. There are many centers today, and City of Hope
is not the only one, that have come to realize how important it
is to think about commercialization first, even at the
very beginning, at the inception, when you are thinking about your project,
your target, your innovation. So, that's what I'm doing now, trying to
bring all this knowledge back to City of Hope and hopefully helping to
many other investigators to really find that path by which we can
translate innovation in a much
cost and time-efficient manner to truly deliver
something that will impact patients.
Thank you. Wonderful. Lots of questions for you.
Bill?
How to follow that? I'll do my best. So my name is Bill Heit.
I'm an MD PhD. I'm a medical oncologist. My PhD is in pharmacology.
And in 1972, I walked
into a lab where I wanted to do my graduate school work
and told the PI that the key to treating and curing
cancer is signal transduction, and I'm going to work on signal
transduction in his lab. And he said, "Well, our lab works on
neuroscience, so see you." But I was very persistent,
and the only problem was that the only signal transduction
pathway known in 1972 was cyclic nucleotide metabolism.
So I was
generally correct, but
too early.
But I spent the next 30 years in academics.
I was the chief of medical oncology at Yale,
and continued to work on signaling and asked a
question that led me to the drug discovery and development
area, a couple.
One wasWere there
different patterns of phosphoproteins in glioblastoma than normal
white matter, normal glia? And it's a very simple experiment, doesn't
take a lot. It just takes a lot of hot ATP and
a very cooperative neurosurgeon who would not only get you a piece of a
glio, but would get you a piece of normal white matter.
And you homogenize it, you incubate it with hot
ATP, with or without calcium, if you're interested in the pathway I was interested
in, and then you run the results out on a gel and see
if there's different bands of phosphorylated proteins.
And it turns out that there was one striking difference in glioblastoma compared to
normal, and it was a protein that was unknown at the time,
so we wound up sequencing and cloning it, and it turned out to be an
elongation factor two. And we
found, ultimately discovered, the kinase.
So we said, "Well, this must be important because there's so much activity in
glio." So then we tried to make a drug, and we, of course,
it didn't do it.
Fast-forward, I joined Johnson & Johnson to start the
oncology therapeutic area, and at one point after
we got things going, I asked if anyone in the group would like to work on this
target, which we did there for about 10 years, and I can't tell you how much money
we spent and never made a drug that was
selective enough to go forward to hit this
target. So I went from academics after 30 years to
industry. I was at Johnson & Johnson for 17 years.
I retired about a year and a half ago, and now I'm back.
I'm a consultant now. I consult for both academics
and in industry.
And as a result,
I've gained a perspective on what it's
like to try to work in
an academic setting and be interested in
developing a product.
I was saying to Vanessa that one of the early things I worked on
was
multi-drug resistance back in the day when that was important.
I guess it's still important. We made a pharmacophore for
p-glycoprotein, the MDR1 product, and actually
licensed the pharmacophore to Vertex, which became a
drug called VX-701, which of course also didn't make it in
the clinic.
So in the process of all this, at Johnson & Johnson, I
went from starting the oncology therapeutic area to head of R&D for the
pharmaceutical sector
and had a model that
turned out to work very well. Part of that
model was the realization that we used to say a great idea
could come from anywhere,
so we source innovation from wherever it originates.
And to be sure, we had our tentacles out around the
world. We set up incubators called JLABS.
We set up innovation centers in cities around the world.
We incorporated our venture fund called JJDC,
and we put our legal teams, our business teams, all outside the
center of J&J so we could strike deals quickly.
At one point, the JLABS had incubated over 1,000 companies.
And one of the drugs that we licensed from a
company was an oral peptide that inhibited
IL-23, and it's now just been approved for
psoriasis and is anticipated
to be an extraordinary drug. So it's not 1 out of 1,000,
but it's not far off-
Yeah
... just to give you an idea. So one of the people that I had the privilege of
working with was Michal Preminger.
Michal ran the technology transfer office at Harvard, and she ran
our Boston Innovation Center. And we wrote an article about a year or
two ago called "Academic Entrepreneurship:
Promise and Perils." It was published in TIBS,
so if you want to read the ups and the downs of it, it's in
that article.
Thank you, Bill.
Omer.
It's going to be impossible for me to follow both of you.
Hi, everyone. I'm Omer Butt. So I am
a regulatory affairs person.
I've been in the regulatory affairs field for about 20 years now.
I started my career as a postdoc. By trade, I
have a PhD in biomedical engineering in stem cell biomechanics.
But when I was working as a postdoc at Ohio State,
this is where my story starts about how I got into regulatory.
I was taking these 48-well Transwell plates, which
have these filters at the bottom used in chemotaxis, very standard stuff,
cut them out with a hot blade, seal it, put
Matrigel in it, and put them into mice to see how angiogenesis
works in the Matrigel. It was pretty simple there.
And I started thinking, "Man, what if we could commercialize this?"
While I was doing that,
FDA reached out for an opening. They were looking for people, recruits,
and said, "Hey, you should come and work in our lab because we're doing something
like that in oxidative stress." So right as a postdoc, I
transitioned to the Center for Biologics at FDA as a CMC
reviewer. The first couple of years, I did a lot
of wet lab work while doing the reviews.
So I helped write the guidance documents
for animal studies, so we were doing oxidative stress models for guinea
pigs versus rats, where the guinea pig is a better model.
We still haven't sold that fully to everyone yet.
It's just because they don't produce ascorbate like humans compared to rats, which
produce, I don't know how many hundreds of mgs of ascorbate a day, which
helps in oxidation.
But the idea was to kind of understand how you could
take a product, which is a simple idea from postdoc and "Hey,
can we commercialize this? Can we make money out of this?"
And boy, was I wrong.
The amount of work that goes intoGetting
something to lift off from an idea
is a lot, right? But once you transition, then that
momentum comes, and it starts gaining the momentum.
You get the right people joining you in, and it gets easier and
easier. I always say the hardest part is to
get in a first-in-human trial. Then it almost puts
into auto-drive, and your results drive it, right?
If the product works, the agency will work with you to get it where it needs to be
into commercialization. So I was with the
agency for about six or seven years, and then I transitioned into
industry. The agency was kind of reshuffling, like they always do
every four years.
I worked with Biogen on expressed proteins,
interferon gamma proteins for a few years, transitioned
to mAbs
with Sanofi and worked on their mAb portfolio with
Regeneron. That was with my team, cirlimab, dipilimab,
alirocumab, all in the space of
manufacturing and kind of how we do tech transfers and how we do next
generation, going from a small bioreactor, a flask in
your lab to 5 liters, 5,000 liters, 15,000
liters, how you compare material.
And then a full circle, I came back into cell therapy, working
on a cell therapy product, which was for ischemic stroke,
and then also kind of diverted into other indications like
ARDS and also working for trauma with the
DoD. Then I had the opportunity to work
on-- I transitioned to working some of the products with Mike Caligiuri
here in the oncology space and NK cells.
And
I think where I've kind of settled, and now I've transitioned actually again to
working for a company called Avectra Therapeutics, which are based out of
UK. They work on precision technology on targeting tumors.
And I think where I've found my love is
where it's very naive from a standpoint of
regulations, where you're young, you're in college, and you have this
IP now, and you want to take it to clinic. How do you sell it?
And that's my job now. I work with companies, and I work currently as the
head of regulatory affairs, but to take product from
R&D into the transition to get into first-in-human trials,
and then look ahead 10 steps and say, "Hey,
you're making this now, and it costs you 500 bucks to make, but
ultimately, can you scale it up? Can you get it to all the patients that need to
get there?" And continuously work with the agency, and I'm sure we'll talk about
this, and you'll have questions about it, how the agency interacts with you through
that process so you can ultimately get to where you want to be.
So I'm looking forward to this conversation.
Great.
By the agency, you mean the FDA?
Oh, the agency, the FDA. Sorry. We call them the agency.
Not the FBI, for example.
Not the FBI or CIA. It's FDA.
So thank you.
As I mentioned earlier, my name is Mike Caligiuri, and
my path is a bit different from the three you've heard in that I've always
been in academia and remain in academia for 40 years.
Just wanted to be a clinician, wanted to be a bone marrow transplanter.
Made my way to the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, where I
was a oncology fellow and did a transplant
fellowship, and I found out that part of the fellowship was you had
to go in the lab for two years,
a requirement. And so not having been in a lab before,
I went in a lab and actually fell in love with lymphocyte
biology, natural killer cells, worked in a lab with a gentleman named
Jerry Ritz,
and
came out of the labs realizing kind of for the first time that I'm
really a scientist that wants to play doctor.
And
ended up using my skills as a clinician to get my first
job at Roswell Park Cancer Institute.
Could no longer afford to live in Boston, had
two kids and needed to get out of
town. Went to Buffalo, New York, much lower cost of
living. Got a wonderful position there, financially
stable, and began my career as
a transplanter. My first job was to build the transplant unit there.
They didn't have a transplant unit at the time.
And also to start my own lab. I had no funding,
and what happened is, over time, the lab got more and
more interesting. We recruited someone to head transplant.
I found success in the lab with funding and publications,
and my lab grew and grew. And
became more and more interested in the science and little less
interested in the clinical, but always kept my clinical practice up as a leukemia
physician.
After
seven years, I got recruited to Ohio State University.
And one of the things that was interesting about going from
both the Farber, where you would have
waited five, six years to become an assistant professor after
completing your postdoc, paid at a postdoc level.
There were a lot of organizations out there that were in need of people that were
presumably well trained and had a good skill set
where you could move much quicker.
And I learned that opportunity was inversely proportional to what was
in place. So if you're at
the Dana-Farber, this outstanding mecca of oncology, you might
wait a long time to get your shot. Whereas if you look outside
of some of the bastions of science
and commercialization, there are a lot of organizations that are looking for
you and are willing to put more resources into you.
And I found that at Roswell Park. They needed a transplant unit.
I wanted to start a lab. When I went to Ohio State, they were
on probation for their cancer center,
meaning they were about to get phased out from NCI
designationAnd so they were in need, so got a good package
to move there and started as head of hematology
oncology, then became director of the cancer center, and ultimately became
CEO of the hospital. When I became CEO of the hospital, I
stopped seeing patients
because I couldn't do my lab and see patients and run the
hospital and be the director of the cancer center.
And that's where the entrepreneurship kind of started.
So first it was
within Ohio State. So we ended up doing very well with
the cancer center. It got refunded several times.
And
I was finding that we were
just
busting at the seams of the cancer hospital, which was right on our campus.
And one of the things I did was propose, with a financial plan, that we build a
new cancer hospital. And that was
tremendously fun and inspiring. We ended up building the third-largest cancer
hospital in America, still to this day.
I think it was at the time, it was $1.1 billion, which was
like the B word wasn't used much in Columbus, Ohio, at the time.
So it was a lot of fun. And the other thing I
found is that we had
very little money to enact the vision that Vanessa
talked about. Tech transfer, this is the largest university in America.
I think they had a budget of like a million dollars.
So you would go to them, and there would just be nowhere to go.
Just inundated from 14 different colleges, different ideas,
very frustrating. So I started something called the Drug Development
Institute and brought some friends from pharma who were
interested in, as Vanessa mentioned, coming back to academia, and
they began to run the Drug Development Institute.
And from that, basically anybody in the university
could come, and they
had the expertise that you've heard from these individuals, the
pathway and the strategy and the resources, and a
number of drugs ended up getting exported to pharma.
And the other thing was that, so these are all just ideas baked within the
university that the university was willing to do.
The other thing was when I became the CEO of the hospital, the cancer
hospital, had to come up with a way to raise money
to really fund the science. The hospital was easy to
fund because it was very profitable in a non-for-profit environment.
And so it was selling bonds, and it paid for
itself many, many times over.
But to fund research, in times like this,
becomes an issue, and people look to leadership to fund it.
So I thought of this, why don't we have this bike event?
It was a flat area in Ohio. They didn't have a bike
event. They really didn't have a run.
And to make long story short, we started a bike event called
Pelotonia, and it's one weekend a year.
It started in 2009, and it went
the first weekend in August in 2009.
And
100% of the money goes to cancer research. There's no overhead.
We set up
a business model where the event, which cost about $2.5 million a year
to put on, is paid for. Safety, state
troopers, food, rock bands, overnight
stay. And
after, I don't know how many years it's been now, must be about
16, 17 years, we've raised
$350 million,
100% of which goes to cancer research, and included the building of
brand new Pelotonia, is the name of the event, Immunology Center.
The reason why I bring that up is that a guy named John Byrd came to me, who
was my head of hematology, and he said, "I need
$100,000 to put this drug into mice.
I think it's going to be a very interesting drug." That drug was ibrutinib,
and John was the first one to put ibrutinib into a
CLL mouse model. And many of you know the story of ibrutinib.
Bill probably knows it best, much better than I do, but it's a multi-billion
dollar drug and has literally changed the face of chronic
lymphocytic leukemia. Anybody diagnosed with it now goes on it or one of
the generational drugs that have since gone and
can have
normal or near normal life expectancy from that drug.
So that started with $100,000 from a bike event
and took off
incredibly well.
So those are things that kind of right within my wheelhouse that there
was no problem with. And then the last one was that
I was thinking, what is it that we have that the world needs?
And one of the things everybody has, if you're an oncologist or you know
family members with cancer, it's you don't know what to do.
Somebody today, find out your uncle has cancer, calls you because you're in the
field.
Who do they see? What do they do? Is this an emergency? What are the next steps?
And really doesn't know. So I was sitting with 120
cancer physicians. Every one did one specific cancer.
And the world was sitting there saying, "How do I talk to that person?" So I
started a company, for-profit company, called Cancer Bridge,
where basically,
I went in partnership with someone who was doing the phone
service for Apple Computers, Apple, the company,
and he ran the telecommunications, and he was in Columbus.
And I told him this idea. He happened to be a cancer survivor.
He said, "I'll bankroll it." And it wasn't much.
We basically used his infrastructure and started this system
where we would go to a company and say, "How would you like it if your
employee heard those three words, you have cancer, have
someone to call who's an expert in that cancer?
We're not trying to take your patient to our hospital.
We're just trying to help your employees."
Employers love this because they love their employees, and
they want them to be safe and healthy and get the best.
So this really took off, and within like a year, we had 100,000
lives covered.I left
after 21 years, Ohio State, and became the president at City of Hope.
At City of Hope, I told them about this idea.
They were thinking, "We'd like to do something." I said, "Oh, well, we have Cancer
Bridge." So we went to Ohio State to buy
Cancer Bridge from them, and
we got all the way to the final signature, and the CFO refused
to sign off on it. So we said, "Let's rebuild
it." So we rebuilt something called Access Hope,
and
Access Hope, we got much more money behind it, much
more entrepreneurial
power behind it from our board. And we
took that from covering 100,000 lives
to at least six million lives right now.
We have the Dana-Farber, Emory,
Northwestern, UT Southwestern, and the Fred Hutch are all
now share ownership of
Access Hope. So
these are both non-for-profit, Pelotonia, and
for-profit,
Cancer Bridge, Access Hope.
And then lastly, Zomer said, "My lab is NK cells." I had
someone come to me and said, "I'd love to fund your lab, but I want to
make money."
Mm-hmm.
And I said, "Okay." So long story short,
we co-founded a cell therapy company. You know this story with cell therapy.
Maybe you don't, but it's had its ups and downs.
Investors have been in, investors are out.
We're now into in vivo,
CAR T, CAR NK. So that's been a whole
different experience, and at first it was within the
organization,
and then it moved out of the organization for a
for-profit company. Had as many as 60 employees.
Now has about a dozen employees. It's been up and down, tops and
turvies, all sorts of things, but we're still plugging away and trying to keep it
going. So
it's been a fun ride.
I've had the pleasure of working with wonderful people, the panelists that you see
here. You need all of them, and so we'll stop there
and open it up for questions, and if anyone has questions, come
up to the microphone, and if you don't have questions, I'll start myself.
Okay.
So
Omer, let me start with you because you talked about your
pathway, but I think there are a couple of things that investigators
need to know, many of which know. But what's a pre-IND?
What does IND stand for? What's a pre-IND?
What's an IND, and what's the difference?
Sure. So,
in the regulatory space, you have a product.
You are ready to take it into clinical trials.
What the FDA has code of federal regulations, and what it
defines is something called an IND, which
most of you have probably heard the term. It's an investigational new drug.
So you have to go through an investigational new drug
pathway, multiple phases of it,
phase one, two, three, and then end up applying for a
commercial license, and all these phases show different aspects
of how the drug develops. So
before the investigational new drug application is filed,
the agency, the FDA, allows you to do something which is called
a pre-IND, and actually, if you're in the cell therapy space,
they also allow you to do with something called the pre-pre-IND, which is now
called the interact meeting. But what a pre-IND basically is,
is to take your baby, a young idea,
and take it to the agency and have a discussion with them and
discuss the development plan for it.
What's the indication you're looking at?
What's your outlook for how are you going to manufacture
it? What dose are you going to use? What are the outcomes you're going to be
looking at in the clinic? And
at this very point, you will realize that the FDA is your
partner in this, right? Not as a partner of your company, but as a
partner in the development of the program because they will provide
you very useful feedback at a pre-IND level
and say, "If you take this into an IND
for an application,
this is likely to move forward appropriately," or, "You have
major gaps right now in your program to have a first-in-human
trial." So it gives you this little area where you can work
on those gaps, so when you go in for your investigational new drug
application to start a first-in-human trial, your chances
of success are much higher. Now, I speak from a regulatory
side, and I speak purely from regulations and getting that going,
but I'm sure people who are trying to build a business model,
if your IND goes in and the FDA says, "We're going to put it on a hold," which
really just means right now that we see a safety issue here.
We're not going to let it move forward.
That's a big no-no from a business aspect of it, right?
As a scientist, it's a hurdle. As a clinician, it's a hurdle.
You try to fix that and move forward, but we don't know how long that's going to
take. If the stock's going to drop, how is that going to
work out? So a pre-IND becomes crucial in your development
program if you want to take that product into clinical trials.
So how do I get in touch with the FDA?
Simple.
There are very clean, laid-out procedures.
Email is your world now. You can email FDA.
On the FDA website, there's plenty of resources where you can just email
them, call them, and they will provide you information how to
officially apply for an application.
So a pre-IND, it's a simple request you make,
and there's very defined pathways on the timing.
When you make a request, how long before the FDA responds to that,
what you then need to provide them, and when they will give you your feedback.
Now, there's no hard and fast rule when you need to
go for a pre-IND. The FDA says, "Hey, come when you're
ready to file your IND in about six to 12 months."
So if you're going to file your IND
early next year, it's probably a good time to have your pre-IND.
And again-The one aspect, too, with
everyone should remember, it's free. It does not cost you a penny.
Well, it will cost you a penny internally to file it, but the FDA does not
charge you anything. They will provide you this feedback
completely free of charge using their experts.
And so-
So email it out, send it to them, send the application, and then you hear back from
them.
And when you do the IND, is that essentially your clinical protocol?
It's a lot more than just the protocol, right?
Okay. What is that?
Yeah. So the IND is split into multiple parts, and at an
early place, you have three extremely important aspects of
it. The clinical protocol, absolutely.
That's going to be your trial design, what your endpoints are going to be.
How do you define success?
I will tell you, in a Phase I IND, safety, safety, safety, right?
The
only thing the FDA cares about really is safety.
You have to show your product is safe. Efficacy is going to come.
You're going to find your dose. You're going to find an efficacious dose if it
works appropriately. Safety. Number two is
what they call CMC, which is chemistry, manufacturing, and controls, which is
basically your process, how you make it. How do you make it in your lab?
How do you make it in a manufacturing facility?
What are the materials you use? What grade are they?
How do you keep it sterile? All that stuff is going to go with that.
And I went through it backwards. The number one thing, or
the number three in this case, is your non-clinical.
Those three are going to define it.
So non-clinical is a key to getting an IND
in. And what a non-clinical is, what in vitro, in
vivo, animal model data do you have to
show that this drug can be taken
into a clinical trial into humans?
If you have a drug that's making mice drop left and right in their model,
it's not going forward. The Code of Federal Regulations
requires you to have a safety study in there in animals.
So it's hard to get away from that.
The FDA is moving now to avoid using a lot of animal studies.
They're saying there's enough data out there.
There's extremely amazing tools out there where you can show with
different ways, but you will have to run a safety study in animals first before you
can take it into humans.
And sometimes that's part of the pre-IND, right?
Absolutely.
Okay.
Your pre-IND will have a big chunk of your in vivo, in
vitro data, your basic idea how you're going to manufacture,
and at least a synopsis of what your clinical trial design is
going to be. You don't have to have everything nailed down.
But you want to have enough in there
for the agency to come back, give you some comments, and you incorporate that.
For those who are right at the cusp of having a
pre-IND meeting, and I will always say this as a regulatory person, as a person
who worked for the FDA,
you just want to hear "yes" from the FDA, because a lot of people want
FDA to agree with their pre-IND. I can tell you 20 questions to ask where they will
just say "yes." You can say, "Hey, we'll run a stability
program." They'll say, "Yes, sure.
That's right." But what you really want to ask is the on the
border, on the fence questions, where you feel they may push back,
but they may also give you very constructive feedback where you can take it all the
way, right? If there's a model that's not perfectly defined
and you think you're going to run an animal study on it, but you know it's really
not going to answer the questions, propose to them and justify why you
don't think that that study is necessary.
And they may come back and say, "You know what?
We'll look at your data that's already out there, and you don't have to run that
study." And that study might be $200,000.
So that's a good time to have that study discussion.
Thank you, Omar.
Can I ask a-- Can I add something, Mike-
Yeah, please. Yeah
... to that? Because I think that's so important.
One piece of advice,
no matter how much experience you or your company has,
when the FDA gives you a piece of advice, you should follow it.
If you don't, you're at your own peril.
Remember, they have seen similar
opportunities from multiple companies.
So they already know often where the problems lie.
So when they're recommending something to you and you think, "Oh, no, that's
crazy," they're doing it for a reason.
And as Omar was pointing out, they want to be your partner.
They'd love to see a great drug get approved, and they know it's not easy.
So when you go for your meetings, and prepare those questions
carefully because they're going to answer them yes or no and have a
discussion.
If they give you advice, it's a good idea to listen to them.
That's great. Thank you. Yes.
Yeah. I have a question about, because most of us in the
academic setting, I understand that, so we're hoping that
we can license
the IP. So is there
any suggestion? I know there's a lot of discussion about the
pre-IND. I think that it's probably a lot more
for us to take on if we don't have-
Yes
... the organization like you guys have.
Yes. That's a great question, and it leads me to a
little broader question for Vanessa.
But thank you for asking that because I've done both, where I've started a
company and also licensed things.
But so Vanessa, broadening out that
question a bit further, when should I
approach my tech transfer office about a
possible patent?
Is it when I have an idea? Is it when I have some data?
Is it before or after a publication?
And what are the options should
the idea resonate with you?
Yeah. So
I would say that it depends on the institution and depends on the
office of technology transfer. There are
someOTTs or OTLs that they
will just give you advice about what's the data that you need to
have a patent and
to be able to have the right claims in that patent application.
But there are other
offices of technology transfer that are expanding today in their role and
responsibilities, and they can help you from the very beginning at the
inception to really think if you are trying to solve a problem or you have a
research project, how to properly, even at the beginning, think
about that development path, that research program, so that you can
start planning on generating the right data from the very beginning.
And I've seen in many cases that in talking to
investigators, they've done this amazing research.
They want to go, they want to file IP, and they
miss in thinking about whether or not you actually have
enough differentiation, do you have the right data for the claims we want to have?
And some of the data that they might have been generating, it's not really what
we need for the application, yet we need them to do additional experiments.
So
my recommendation
right now, again, as academic medical centers and investigators are
thinking much more about I want to protect my research because they want
to be able to commercialize, is incorporate the
feedback about what's going to be required for that patent
application and commercialization path very early on, like
the FDA permitting is something similar.
Just get that advice, have that conversation. It's always really helpful.
And-
And sorry. And something that I think it's also really important.
Very often we fail to miss the opportunity that you might actually
find a partner that might want to license your IP very early on.
If the Office of Technology Transfer knew that you were working in this project,
very often they are part of the business development team.
There might be opportunities for them even to help you to find partners that will
work with you on developing that-
And license, possibly license.
Becoming the licensee for your research.
Yes.
Bill?
Just to comment.
Yeah.
Some universities actually
have IP lawyers who are experienced in the
field. My experience is that most don't.
And
so when we've looked at
opportunities,
we're very concerned about the advice that the
young entrepreneur has gotten.
So very important to find an IP attorney
who has done this many, many times.
And if your university has it, great.
But most universities have technology transfer offices but
may not have the sophistication that a true IP lawyer
has.
Yes. That's very true. And sometimes between
yourself paying for that, which is what would end up happening,
and a university not having it, the
university's legal department might have an arrangement
with an external firm that they call on
regularly that probably isn't best in class
but has done this a lot and is a good price, frankly-
Mm-hmm
... and can get you some advice, but sometimes that advice can
be wrong.
So,
having a strong patent application
leads to a smoother transition to getting a patent ultimately, which can take many
years, by the way. And
one thing I'll mention, and feel free to comment, is that
it's very important that you have your patent application submitted
before you publish anything.
That's true.
You can't have an abstract out there.
Mm-hmm.
You could probably have, and Vanessa, you can comment on this, an oral
presentation in a small group somewhere and kind of
not have been recorded,
in any way, shape, or form, and still get away with
being able to submit your patent. But once the public has
access to your data, your data is essentially, correct
me if I'm wrong, no longer patented.
Mm-hmm.
And this is a big problem in universities where they don't have sufficient
staff or interest or finances, one or the other, or
sometimes all of those to handle what you're going to do.
You end up submitting the paper, or you submit it for an abstract because that's
important for your career.
Yeah. And
that's extremely important because it happens very often as well that we get
investigators, "Oh, I want to submit this paper to Nature.
We need to file a patent now." And you don't want to be hurried on doing the
patent application, so the soonest that you can work with your office of technology
transfer, the best to plan not only for what you want to do, but also
for future publications, so that you don't have to really then rush in a patent
that then you are not going to be able to license because it might not have the
right claims. You might be missing something that then the
industry wants to see on that patent application.
So all that planning early on is becoming more and more important.
And the other component that I think the reason why I'm
recommending, and that's what we are doing now at City of Hope, really working with
them from the very beginning, that you need to be thoughtful that protecting your
IP or your research through a patent application, that's an equal.
You are going to be able to commercialize.
You need to understand freedom to operate.
Are there other licenses that you will need to take to be able to commercialize
that technology? It's much more complex than just having a
patent.
Yes.
Hello. I'm a postdoc and also a practicing nurse
practitioner in a rural oncologist, so not like an academic center.
Yeah.
And, I just recently pitched an idea to our clinic management about
setting up a symptom care clinic. We can proactively, like people
start a new therapy, we can give them an option to come into the
clinic within a few days, address symptoms, answer any questions
about potential toxicities. And I kind of run into this
likeAnd I did a pitch, like a business
plan. I
wrote the hours we would need, how we would do it, what's the personnel needed.
Right.
But basically, the answer I got was, "Well, we make money on planned
care utilization too, so
can you show us that there's money in it?" And I don't have that
background.
Mm-hmm.
So
how do you sell an idea to a clinic management?
Or are there any resources for
clinicians like myself? If you want something done,
where do you go to get the data to back it up?
Yeah. That's a great question, and I'll just give a little personal story and then
ask anyone to comment. But when I had this idea for
Pelotonia, I was telling you about, the bike event, and I did the
hospital after Pelotonia. And the first thing when I just became the CEO
was do Pelotonia and just get a bike event.
And-
It's a great idea, Mike.
I remember
the chair of my board who was the one saying, "Hey, what are you going to do to the
foundation board, the fundraising board?
What are you going to do to raise money that's different?" I said, "I have this
bike
idea." And she said, "Well, let's do a business plan." I'm like, "Okay.
What's that?"
So she happened to be an accountant and someone who was very
passionate about the hospital,
and she put together a business plan. I didn't know what a business plan was.
So,
getting together with someone that understands your organization
but also has a financial background, maybe there's
a
financial advisor on your board of your clinic
who'd be very interested in working with you, and they know money.
Mm-hmm.
But other thoughts to answer the question? Bill, and then Vanessa.
I-
Go ahead.
I would say yes, try to find someone within your organization that might be
supportive and wants to help you with that business plan pro forma, and really
making
a financial case. But, the other thing I want to share is
that I live in Boston, so I've been there, and, of course, in Boston, there are
many people all the time, students, everybody wants to start a company.
And it's very common to go to networking events where you just start chatting to
people and try to find someone. Tell them what you are trying to do, and you will
always find people very willing to help you for free
because, again, that's another option.
Just network and try to go to these places where there are more
entrepreneurial
leaders that might be able to give you a hand in your business plan.
Yeah. So I'm actually working with a company who has done a
piece of what you're doing,
and has a business plan. And,
if you're around after the meeting, I will make the connection to that company.
I think you will find it
perhaps
helpful to what you want to do.
Good. Thank you. Yes.
Hi, good morning. My name's Hillary Keely. I'm from the Sontag Foundation.
We fund brain cancer research both through grants as well as venture.
Yes.
And I would love to hear your thoughts on what types of preclinical data
packages get you excited, and both from the
basic science looking to translate, as well as from later
stage science packages and what you think that investigators should bring in.
Yes, great. So, I'll just give a couple thoughts as the least
informed.
Just what lessons I've learned. In
my experience and from
being involved in panels like this, it's very difficult for a
scientist to go to Big Pharma.
There's just many because they
are so inundated by so many biotech
companies that have taken the work of
investigators and put it
on financial steroids and brought it to the pre-IND and
IND stage.
And
Dr. Hight will tell you that of all those that come to them,
it's one in 250 that they might...
The number's probably greater.
So,
there has to be a bridge between
the investigator with the neat preclinical data,
and pharma. So I'm just
suggesting that pharma-- I'm just going to say don't jump from
that to pharma. But I'll leave it to my colleagues to tell you how
to transition.
Yeah.
So it's sound advice.
So I'll give you an example that Mike alluded to, which happened to be
ibrutinib, which became Imbruvica, and why
we were so interested at J&J in
that drug or that type of drug. And the reason was there
was absolutely compelling genetic
evidence that the target, which is called Bruton's
tyrosine kinase, or BTK,
if you could inhibit the activity of that
kinase, that B cells would disappear, and the
genetic evidence that there's a hereditary disorder called Bruton's
agammaglobulinemia, where that enzyme is not functional
and they don't make B cells. So we thought if you could inhibit
the enzyme
and do it safely, that you would likely
have a very good drug. So that kind
of very strong genetic information
is perhaps the pinnacle. Unfortunately,
it doesn't happen that much. But in
return, there has to be very strong
biological plausibility for what you're doing, number one.
SoIn the package that would come to us,
we would
look for a few things. One is
the quality of the science. Is it biologically plausible?
Is it the genetic evidence? Is there genomic evidence?
Number two,
we would want to know, and I'm sure other companies too,
not if your idea worked, but when it works, will it
be transformational? And this is the problem when you come to a big pharmaceutical
company. Remember, from a good idea to a
product could be 10 to 20 years, and the
market's not standing still. So it
becomes an innovation threshold.
So your idea, if it works,
would have to be truly transformational for a big
pharmaceutical company to get involved.
So to Mike's point,
early on, your best bet, I think, and we talked about
this a little bit in another meeting yesterday is to talk to a
biotechnology company.
They're going to have different
exit points. So where a pharmaceutical company has to get a drug to
market,
a biotechnology company has to get enough compelling evidence,
oftentimes for a large pharmaceutical company to acquire the drug.
So this is the kind of, I think,
approach that most people are taking now.
They have a good idea, it has biological plausibility, they go to a biotech, or
they start a biotech. They develop a compelling package of
information, compelling enough that a big pharmaceutical
company is willing to make the investment, and that can be hundreds of millions of
dollars to get it over the finish line.
So wouldn't go to big pharma right away.
Would get your
biological feasibility, and if you have a lead, even better, lead
asset, and work with a biotechnology company who might
have a different threshold, not of quality,
but a different exit plan that might be more amenable
to something very early.
Thank you. Omer? Yeah, go ahead.
I'm just going to add one thing,
from a data standpoint, more to a regulation standpoint, and
what the pharma companies might see dollar signs at,
which is kind of the pathways. From an FDA standpoint,
it's all right now. It's rare disease, unmet need.
Rare disease, unmet need, right? Where do you find unmet needs?
So I think when you start looking at indications,
sub-cancers, all that stuff,
anywhere there's an unmet need, the agency steps in
as right next to you and be like, "Let's get this forward as quickly as possible."
And then the pharma looks dollar signs at that because there is a
lot of regulatory pathways that get them to the finish line
much faster if it is in that space. So just a thought.
And glioblastoma would be in that space.
There you go.
So you might consider
asking someone in biotech as a focus, and there's thousands
of biotech companies, as a focus in glio,
to sit on your board of your foundation.
And that might be attractive to them for two reasons.
Altruistic, but also they get a look at maybe you have a scientific
advisory board, or they sit on your board, and they do you the favor of listening
to the science. So there's an opportunity for them to
get the first look at the science that's coming out of your foundation.
It's a possibility. And we have a meeting that
Bill and I co-chair with another person, Chris
Barton, called the AACR Oncology Industry
Partnership, and all the big pharma
present there. And they say what they're working on, and they say what they're not
working on. And I think I saw Gilead is working on
glioblastoma.
There you go.
So you might consider going to that meeting and talking to them.
And they have their business development people. Not that they're going in...
As Tulie said, they're a big pharma and they're not going to...
But they might have ideas about, "Oh, you should talk to this
biotech company." So Vanessa, do you have a comment before we go to next question?
I actually know the Suntark Foundation very well because I founded the Brain
Tumor Investment Fund, that is the fully owned subsidiary of the National Brain
Tumor Society. And we created this investment fund
precisely to fund innovation from academia to
cover this valley of death, especially for research for glioblastoma.
And that was in 2019, I believe.
It's been slowly, but we've done great, invested in eight companies, got
one exit. And I think that what it's important, especially when we think
about brain cancer or other very
high unmet needs in oncology, is that investors and the
pharmaceutical industry and everyone wants to see the risk in.
It's a very highly risky space where there has
been so many failures. So that's a component for you.
And I think you should get back and reach out.
I think we
talked about working together four years ago, and never
happened. Might be the right time to talk again.
Okay.
Wonderful. Thank you, Vanessa. Yes.
Hey. This is Hakimeh Ebrahimi Nikh from Ohio State.
I'm junior faculty.
So I have a question. When we have PCT
application filed, we have 18
months to decide on if the patent
application will be filed for Europe, for Japan,
only US, and we are talking about hundreds of
thousand dollars.
As a beginner
... practically how I can pitch my
patent application to industry. Should I get the
phone and start calling different companies
and talk about the patent application?
How can I start during that 18 months
to bring up, hopefully, some investors in that?
So we'll ask Vanessa to answer this, but you need a business
development person at your organization.
That's what that person does. Their job
is to find businesses that help
develop your idea. But Vanessa, you.
You are not the one, exactly. You should have someone in your organization to do
this for you, because they know the industry, they know who
is looking for what, and they will be able to then determine
as well, based on the potential commercialization path, in which markets that you
want to expand the application, right?
And a lot of times they have had stellar careers in industry,
where they're connected, they're wired, they know who to call, they have friends.
Yep.
And so I'm
not sure, but I-
They do have the advertise page, and they said they did it.
So during that 18 months,
there's nothing that they can help with, I should just- ...
relax.
Did you try a business development person?
Yes.
I think from tech transfer office-
Yeah
... they made a one-page business-
Yes
... yeah.
Yeah, so, I'd make an appointment to literally personally go see
the head of tech transfer to say, "This is what you need."
And, because you're right, patents
get very expensive very quickly, especially if you want
to retain your patent internationally.
Mm-hmm.
It can be more than several hundred thousand dollars.
So,
the other possibility,
really it would come through your tech transfer office.
Sometimes they're board members, but universities usually don't like you
seeking out
their funding, their
philanthropists directly.
Mm-hmm.
So through your organization, if you have a chair of your department, might be
helpful to introduce you to people that might like the idea.
Because sometimes there are grateful patients who are very wealthy and
very interested, they have a passion to develop something,
and
they want to make money.
Mm-hmm.
Which is a good thing. So.
Mike, the other thing I would say, not in particularly in your case,
but what we've seen many, many times is people rush to
file patents way too early.
Mm-hmm.
Take your time, because things change.
And once you start doing that, you're on this clock, and now you're worried
about patents all over the world. So really, very
early on, if you think you really have something,
the other reason to get a good patent attorney to guide you, when
is the best time to file? Because people file patents too
early, they're easy to work around, too late and
someone has swooped in. So it's a little bit of the Goldilocks problem.
That's why you really need an expert to guide you.
Yeah. That's good advice. Yes.
Hey, Ned Waller, Emory.
Hey, Ned.
Nice to see you, Mike.
Good to see you.
So
everyone talks about the valley of death.
It's more like the Darian Gap, right?
It's dark, it's dangerous, there's no map,
and it's just hard to bridge the
development stage from great ideas in academia to
actually doing a phase one clinical trial.
I'll just make a comment about patents, at least at Emory, they'll file
U.S. patents, but not
international patents without
some kind of licensee, because the cost is too much.
So we had a great idea.
We filed patents early, maybe too early,
but have lots of issued patents. I think altogether we have
33 patents worldwide. But that took money,
so we formed a company, got seed funding, a couple of fast track
SBIRs, started CMC. But there's still a
$10 million gap to get into clinical trials, a
phase one trial. And I think,
Bill maybe mentioned, big pharma, $10 million
doesn't register on their radar. It's
below the
visibility of what they're going to invest in.
And
VCs, every time we talk to people, they say, "Well, come back when you have phase
one clinical data." Which is reasonable, because the risk of
failure is 90, 95% at our
stage, if you look at the data. But it's just a
very
challenging position to be in, and I don't know if the panel
has insight about how to navigate the Darian Gap.
Yeah, there are... Well, I'm not going to tell Ned
anything you don't know, but angel investors,
there's
sometimes within your community,
I know this was true at Ohio State. I live in Puerto Rico right now, it's true
there. There are groups of people that get together and are looking for people to
pitch ideas. And they'll give hundreds of thousands,
sometimes 10,000, sometimes 100,000, towards ideas that
are well developed,
just in your community. In Atlanta, I'm sure there-
So we've done that with Karitsu, and there are people who probably think
they're smarter than they are, who are
a doctor with cash flow.
Yeah.
We don't need hundreds of thousand dollars, we need $10 million now.
It's sort of beyond the scope of angels.
I hear you. Yeah. Without the investor.
Grateful patient, maybe. Vanessa, do you have a comment? And then Bill.
The only thing I want to... It's a challenge.
The investment industry is what it is. It's always a challenge.
I think an opportunity for academic medical centers is to
de-risk the asset early on before you spin it out in a company.
Something we are doing, for example, at City of Hope, we are lucky that we
have GMP facilities in our phase one infrastructure.
So basically, by the time you are filing an IP and the companies that we are
planning on starting now, they are clinically the risk asset.
So the cost structure then and the value of the asset once you are starting
the company, it's different. So as much as you can try to
build that phase one, the risk assets, before
starting your company, it's going to help in the investment thesis as well
afterwards.
Really good advice.
That is really difficult, that's why the term.
One of the things, perhaps this will be helpful,
I used the term at J&J. I call it the Velcro effect.
Big companies have a lot of loops. You need to know what those loops
are, the precise areas, and that's what Mike was referring to about this partnering
meeting we had. They tell you the things they're really interested in,
and if you have the hooks for those loops,
you begin to increase the probability that they might
take an early risk in a pre-clinical
asset.
If it's
tangential to the major interests
of the R&D group at the company,
that makes it more difficult. But if you're really right on,
and I think right on in two regards,
number one, perhaps the target that they're looking for.
Number two, perhaps the molecule.
But I think at Johnson & Johnson, I'll give you a very specific example,
it's the disease. So some companies, J&J, I
think Pfizer has done the same thing, they're very
disease-centric. And if you have a drug
that J&J, let's say, is going to be the next great myeloma drug or the next great
prostate drug, even though it's very early,
that's a very strong set of hooks for those loops.
So maybe that would help. But I feel your pain.
Thank you.
Thanks, Ned. Yes.
Theme on this microphone. Jake Burchuk, also from Emory University.
I'm a medical oncologist and scientist, work in the diagnostic space,
actually, rather than drug development, and
interested if you have any feedback on when...
Another question along the lines of when is the right time to seek
external funding. Feeling that tension of what do
you give up in terms of ownership and/or equity,
financial equity by taking potentially outside money too early,
and is it worth, as you alluded to, Vanessa, trying to scrounge together
institutional funding or philanthropy to get a
diagnostic to a CLIA-approved state before seeking
external funding, and where is that sweet spot in terms of
retaining ownership and equity?
The answer is yes.
So just for the audience, there's non-dilutional funding
and dilutional funding. So non-dilutional funding is when you're
using funds that aren't going to dilute your equity, your
ownership.
And so
I think
I can't speak for everyone, but the advice would be you can get
$2 or $3 million from SBIR for a good
diagnostic,
and with very
light strings attached. You essentially keep all of your
equity.
And you will find
that as soon as you get into
private equity, venture, angel funding,
you will have a rapid decline
in your equity because the risk has shifted
from you to them. And any venture
person knows that they're doing 10 deals like yours with the hope that two
will work.
So, they have to have a lot of equity
because they're not going to get nine.
So that would be the advice is to look very...
Especially with a diagnostic because you can keep the cost
down and to really pursue the SBIR.
I mentor someone who has a diagnostic, and he just got
a $2.5 million SBIR, and he went
to something very much like JLABS,
which again, reduced his infrastructure, and he has
100% ownership, and he's moving towards the CLIA
certification. So
that's personal, but see what others say.
No, I like the scrounging around approach.
It sounds like that's a good one.
Because
a couple of things, diagnostic space is hard.
The recent
failure of the Grail, a very large Grail study, the Galleri test,
isn't helping.
And to Mike's point,
once you get involved with a company or a venture
fund,
there are people there who've done hundreds of deals.
And
one of the things in this article that I wrote some years ago with Paul Stoffels,
"Nature Communications," about the five criteria we looked at
J&J, one is are the deal terms fair?
Now, that sounded very funny to the commercial people at J&J.
"What do you mean by fair?" And what I found and what you have to be on
the lookout for, people who've done hundreds of deals
know every trick in the book to get your company,
and
they're often hidden somehow in the milestones.
So if you can get non-dilutive money before
you deal with a big company or venture capital,
I think that's very sound
adviceAgain, it's very
tough, and the diagnostics space is a little tougher.
But on the flip side, as Mike pointed out, you don't need quite as much money.
You might not need $10 million at the next stage.
But beware,
I had multiple examples where the deals would come forward, and I would say
to our team, "Those terms are not fair to the entrepreneur."
And they would say, "What do you mean?
We'll own half the company." I said, "Yeah, and they'll never come back to us
again." So I think be on the lookout, try to get
non-dilutive funds,
and when you're ready to go to a VC or to a
company,
bring some people with you who've done deals before,
people who have entrepreneurial experience,
because you have to be on the lookout.
Yes.
Yeah, I have a question for Omar.
So I'm so happy to hear that the FDA is very
supportive of rare cancer study.
So do you mean because of the rare cancer, do you
think FDA will be happy to
support one type
of rare cancer? Of course, ideally, if we can
include as many type of rare cancers as possible,
but is there any chance for the FDA to say that, "We
only focus on one type of rare cancer?"
So
that's my first question for Omar, and my question for Mike and Vanessa
is that
you guys, luckily you have the GMP facility.
Is that open for outside institutions?
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, so
there's no specific
rare cancer that they support one or the other.
I think the whole ideology is there's a lot of need
out there where there's no treatment for, or the treatment is just
not right. So if you have a particular
molecule that you want to take into an IND or a pre-IND that is specific for
a rare cancer, that's totally fine. That's great, actually.
And they have the expertise across the board.
There's a lot of great clinicians at the FDA who look at it and say, "Yep,
this is something that we really need out there for patients." So absolutely.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, and there is a specific definition for
what are called orphan diseases.
Orphan, yeah.
And you get special, as Omar said earlier, special treatment with your
patents, your life expectancy or your patent.
City of Hope does do a lot of external contract work.
Mm.
It's largely cell therapy,
not small molecule.
But there's certainly CROs that will do it.
Yeah, who should I reach out to?
I'm happy to talk to you, and I can point you to the right person.
Thank you.
It's a woman named Tabby Ashan.
Mm-hmm.
But...
We do also antisense oligonucleotides and a few other things.
Yeah.
So go ahead. Yes.
Oh, good morning. My name is Ugonna Ezumigwe.
I'm a PhD candidate at the University of Georgia, so I'm very early in my career,
but-
Yeah
... I'm very interested in the business side of things.
So I was wondering how you all deal with maybe in the beginning stages of your
product idea of what you're trying to create, there's a lot of
maybe critique about how niche it is and how difficult it might be to actually do
it. How do you navigate listening to the advice of experts to
modify to eventually maybe commercialize what you're trying to
do, while also maintaining the integrity of the product you've
created so it can still reach those audiences that you wanted it to
reach?
Yeah. Great question. Who wants to start?
I can.
Most important thing,
you're early in your PhD or your postdoc, or?
PhD.
PhD, so you're really just starting.
Really important to have a great group of mentors,
and hopefully someone that's had some success in that
regard. But you can think of people
that complement one another, like the people on this panel.
None of us are the same. We have
biotech, big pharma, regulatory,
strict academic,
but all of us look to commercialization.
So
I would say, because with not knowing the product, nor should you describe it
here, I would say the most important thing is to put together a group of
people at your university or outside of university
who would be willing to help you, guide you,
because one of the things you want to learn early on
is,
is your idea
feasible for commercialization?
Or maybe unbeknownst to you, there's
already work out there that would supplant it.
So I'd say external advice would be really important.
Bill?
So years ago, I received the best career advice I ever got, I was a little more
advanced in my career than you were at the time, from a person that
younger people in the audience won't know, but great drug developers like Renzo
Conetta will, who's going to ask the next question,
named Don Coffee.
Don had trouble graduating from high school because he was
dyslexic but held, I think, five professorships at Johns Hopkins
when I met him.
And he gave me career advice, which I will share with you, and so you could
take the note because it's very important. Are you ready?
Yeah.
He said two things. Number one, "Bill," he said, "Do what makes you
tachycardic." And I said, "Okay, I'll write that down." And
then he said, "And stay above the s**t." And I wrote that down, too, and I think it
was the best career advice I ever got.
So follow your passions, don't listen to all the crap that will go around
you, get good advice, get a good team, and
you will have an enjoyable career.
Good.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Yes.
I actually have a question, follow up with Bill's advice.
I'm a
junior faculty in the Medical University of South Carolina, but I'm a basic
scientist. I'm a biochemist, but I feel like
some of my research, in the future, may have
the potential to be commercialized.
But as a junior faculty, practically, we're struggling with
being judged by how much funding is he getting, how you get a tenure, all
these kind of... What's your advice for that, practically?
Yeah. One of the things to think about, if you're really passionate
about getting an idea to a product,
think about joining a biotechnology company or going into industry.
That's all they do. And
you'll bring a very important skill.
And you might find that no one's going to worry about how many
papers you published. They're going to be more concerned about your
science and how it's moving toward a product.
So that
could be-
Yeah
... an alternative pathway that a lot of people take.
Yeah. And, I would add to that, or big pharma, which
has its own set of basic
laboratories with the same goals.
One thing I would tell you is that, just from my
observations only, is that when you go into biotech,
which is incredibly exciting
field,
industry,
there's a lot of turnover because the money comes and
goes.
And I've had that with my own startups, and that's just the nature
of it. As was said by the panel, things take time.
Investors get fickle, meaning they, all of a sudden, one leaves, they all
leave. One's in, they're all in. But in big pharma,
there's much more stability. It's unusual
for people like Bill and Renzo, who spent their careers,
very senior in the highest hierarchy of big pharma, to be
at
more or less a single institution. There's a lot of movement.
I'm sure Vanessa could speak to that.
Mm-hmm.
Well.
Yes. And I
actually want to build into what Bill mentioned, that
something that really surprised me when I left academia and went to industry is
that nothing changed. You do the same science, the same
innovation, the same research. So I think it's also important to demystify
what going into industry means-
Yes
... for academic investigators, because I did incredible
science when I was in industry, and I worked with incredible scientists.
And if this is something that you really are passionate, just I would
support to explore going to industry, where you can free your mind and
just focus. You are measured by the success in the science that you
do. You are not measured by the many papers or how many
grants you publish. So you can actually get the right incentives to
pursue what you want to do.
Great advice.
Thank you.
I'll say something that all my colleagues, I think will help.
The quality of the science in industry is much better.
Sounds crazy, right? It's the rigor.
Mm-hmm.
Because in academia, we have to have the science good enough
to get something published in a good paper, a good
journal, get a good grant. It's reviewed by
peers.
And in industry, we answer to a much higher authority, and
that's the FDA and the other regulators. And they don't miss a thing.
So every step of the way
has to be at very, very high rigor and
within very, very narrow specs, especially when you get to the CMC
side. So what you'll find is the
ability to do very high quality
science in a very rigorous way to
ensure reproducibility from the earliest experiments you're doing all along
the way. Because if you don't, at the end of the day, you're not going to have a
drug.
And the difference, I think,
in
academia,
there's much more creativity.
There's different type of creativity in industry.
In academia, you make discoveries. You want to discover new knowledge.
You want to generate new knowledge. In industry, you want to discover new drugs.
So it's different, but the rigor of the science
because of the reviews,
and FDA sees everything,
is different. So you'll find that the science is great.
And people are very rigorous about it.
And the people who are managing the science
know a lot, and they want the experiments to be very
reproducible in multiple models to take it along, where you start making
larger and larger investments.
Thank you.
Thank you. Yes. Going to have this question, and then Renzo, I want to give you
the opportunity to talk about your non-for-profit that we talked about-
Mm-hmm
... if you'd like to.
Yeah.
Good morning. Thank you for the talk. Amazing talk.
I wanted to ask about what do you recommend as a mindset
for early researchers who want to leap in industry?
Because as your responses just already mentioned,
it's mystified around, it's different, but it's usually the
same, just with much more rigor. And I want to know
where do you stand right now because each one of you have different
expertise in the field. What do you recommend for those early
researchers to go forward? Because most of the academia
researchers
don't translate really well into industry then because they want to prove every
concept.
Mm-hmm.
They want to go and minimal viable product and get it done.
So because all of you have different expertise, what's your mindset
on what it should be?
Mm-hmm.
And Mike,
just to make sure I understood the question,
you'd like to know
what are the characteristics of a person who would do well in industry?
Is that the idea?
Yeah. And
who should he or she go through-
Ah.
-to get there?
Okay.
Because it is a completely different mindset between-
Yeah
... the mechanistics to-
Yeah. I hear
... develop a product.
I hear you. So number one, I think you're making a good point.
In industry, you're often working on a team
on the same project, right? So,
a team has decided this would be a very good target, and depending on what
area of science you're on, you might be working on
structural biology aspects of the target to try to find the drugable
site. If you're a chemist, you might be working on
different
in silico models to develop compounds that might
fit into that pocket. If you're a biologist, you might be
working on the models.
So many different things, but you are working on a team.
You don't come in in the morning and say,
usually, "Boy, I had this great idea last night when I woke up.
I'd like to work on it." Sometimes you can do that, but most of the time you're
on a team
working on a project. And I think if you go and look at
the sites of big companies and probably biotechs, at the HR sites,
you get a sense of what they're looking for, what positions are open,
and what level.
And based on where you are in your career, you look for the
match. I think that's what you're driving at. Is that right?
Yeah.
Yeah. I want to-
Tessa, any comment?
Yeah. So, I'm reflecting on myself
when I transition. I think it's important to understand that when you
go to industry, you move away from the "I" and you go to the "we." It's
all about teamwork, and if you don't have that mindset, you're going to struggle in
industry. The second thing that it's really important in going to industry is
that you need to build
somehow that pragmatism, that what you are doing is no longer for your paper or
your grant, is to develop a product that can go to the patients.
And we are in industry much more, again,
thoughtful when we think we've tried enough times and
it's time to stop and move on. So really not getting in love
with your projects is like, "This is my project.
I still want to keep going." There is that many times that we will try
from different angles, different technologies, different perspective, but at some
point we are going to make the no-go decision, and we are going to switch to the
next project. At the end, it's all for the best of the patients.
So as long as you have that mindset, you can succeed. Yeah.
Thank you.
Renzo, did you want to talk a bit about your...
Good morning. I'm Renzo Granetta.
I'm retired.
I used to lead the Bristol Myers Squibb Cancer Research
Group until my retirement in a monogamous
relationship with the company
for many years.
Many years ago, together with the FDA, we
created a workshop to help
young investigators, people that wanted to start younger
companies,
to learn how to navigate the drug development
process, and that was called the Accelerating
Anticancer Agents Development and Validation.
Recent events
have made it so that the agency
is no longer
able or willing to
continue this
activity. So together with three friends and
colleagues,
a surgeon from Duke;
Kim Lyerly,
medical oncologist from Chicago, former president of ASCO,
Rich Schilsky;
and
a statistician, Tom Fleming from Seattle; and myself,
we founded a not-for-profit foundation to continue
this work. And there is a need, and the need
that I see is obvious. A lot of small biotech
companies are entering the scenario of cancer
drug development, but very few lack
the knowledge, the tradition, the connection with the
regulatory agency that have proven to be successful and
that have enabled to utilize the instruments that the agencies
always provide.
Yes.
So
now there is this foundation we restarted.
We had a 2025 workshop. We had
114 attendees. We will have another
one in November.
People like Rick Pazdur,
Peter Marks, who has joined our board of directors,
Rob Califf, have accepted to come and
participate to the event. So there is a
need, and this need should be really
helped. Now, let me add one more thing.
Yeah.
And that has to do with the question that arose before.
There are
new opportunities, new entities that are
emerging that can help the starting of
a new project. I mentioned two.
And I'm mentioning them because I've been
personally involved with them.
One is purely not-for-profit
advocacy related, and there are these
organizations, and you can name them, the Leukemia & Lymphoma
Society that now is called the Blood Cancer
United
organization.Pancan for
pancreatic cancer.
You
name it, there are many of them. Many of them have grown
to provide, for free,
the advice that is regulatory and also
legal for people that have brilliant
ideas that might
cater to the particular pathology that they have in
mind. So keep that in mind. Second thing, believe it or not, there
are also some government
activities. I'm mentioning the one that I know the
best, which is the Cancer Prevention Research
Institute of Texas, which was
voted
by the voters of Texas in a
bipartisan proposal to establish
funding to support cancer research,
with the price is to bring scientists into
the state of Texas. But the
program and the process by which this funding
are provided, and these are significant funding, the state of Texas
is rich,
are very rigorous. Just to give you an idea,
nobody who is from the state of Texas judges the
value of the proposals that have been
sent in for this grant. So again, there
are a number of other less traditional entities that
can help a good idea to be developed.
And on top of that, you heard the other one that have been mentioned from the
podium today.
Yes.
Lorenzo, would it be possible for people to chat with you after
the session about the non-for-profit to see if there might be an opportunity
for them to attend?
I'd be glad.
Great.
I'd be glad to.
Thank you so much.
And I will have another comment, but I will make it in the next session about-
I was just going to say, Bill, do you want to tell them about the next session?
And then Omer, do you have a comment?
I just have a comment to add on. The FDA also, if you're in a
space where you've reached and thinking about pre-INDs and
even further before that, FDA itself has a
lot of resources. A lot. They do
SBIR workshops. They do entrepreneur workshops, and everything, again, is
free. The only problem with FDA, like anything government, is they don't
advertise it properly. So, sign up for mailing lists,
FDA mailing lists. There's a lot of that where you can sign up and they invite you.
They tell you to come over to Silver Spring, Maryland and
sit down, and you get to meet these scientists who are your reviewers.
So it's always great to have that one person you've
met at the agency and be like, "This person's just like me." So,
that fear goes away. It's an icebreaker. So definitely look into that.
Bill, do you want to chat about the next session?
Sorry, I have to do it. It's just for fun, but it's a
caveat because also it's part of my personal experience.
You can go to Y Talks anytime you want.
If you happen not to be a US
citizen- ...
you can't.
Yeah.
So you need to give it three months advance, da, da,
da. But this is not the current administration.
It's the history of the government.
Yeah.
So be careful if you're not an American.
Okay.
Yes.
What?
So yeah. Thanks, Mike. So, the next session was designed
to not just be a continuation of this discussion, which we will
do, but to go sort of the next steps
beyond in how we actually go from when you actually
have started your biotech, how you begin to think
through of getting it all the way to the market.
And so it'll be partially a continuation, partially overlap.
We have some very experienced
panelists, just like this panel, so please stay
tuned. It starts in about 20 minutes.
It starts in 20 minutes.
Right here.
Yeah. And right in this very room.
Yeah. Good. Well, thank you everyone for your attention.
I hope you have a wonderful meeting.
Nice to meet you, Vanessa.
Yeah. Likewise. Very conversational.